michael irvin joining us Mike how are
you today I'm okay if you're telling me
that I got a quarterback without there
not knowing my system I'm taking Tom
Brady if you're giving me the
quarterback and his system that's just
what I would do but Russell Wilson I
think you could put him in Green Bay
system or New England system and he
would still be able to lead you on a
two-minute Drive yes Wilson is is
incredible incredible but but Aaron
Rodgers is is everything just from a
quarterback standpoint I call him God's
gift to the quarterback position this do
here is incredible man and that's why
and you know you see some of the teams
like this year at the Minnesota Vikings
even even my Dallas Cowboys all right
this year it's open for everybody
because the Aaron Rodgers is not out
there stopping everybody it's just a
different season without in Iraq what
did you make that shoot out did it say
more about the Texans and deshaun Watson
or Seattle and Russell Wilson or
Seattle's lack of defense there at home
against a rookie quarterback I think so
much about the song Watson and I've been
talking about that all year you know
just just when you see somebody take his
college team going back-to-back
championship games playing that
professional team that plays at the
college level call alabama and do what
he did against that team you knew like
he has something special in a dabble
sweet he tried to tell I know the
football so I've been to another round
okay I call him douche or Michael Jordan
Watson you focus everything and he's
just been you've been incredible man I
know not only like watching them play
I like watching how his team is act
around him I told Jerry Jones about
those saying during the preseason stop
watching the games games don't even
matter watch how people act towards the
young guys on the sideline that
tell you if their young rookie should be
playing I agree it's it's a great point
and I noticed that early with deshaun
Watson and I saw that in the new New
England game where you could tell they
were following him and that's what you
want with a team to follow your leader
Michael you can see him every Sunday NFL
gameday morning at 9:00 Eastern Thursday
Night Football this week bills in the
Jets exclusively on NFL Network
would you take away from the Cowboys
game put on the map but now I love what
the bills do I there there's nothing
special there's no marquee names but you
know that it they're not given up they
never quit they play hard and it's sort
of fun to watch that it's just it's a
little different blueprint there then
but then we're used to seeing with NFL
teams you know you don't know how to get
it done sometimes you look back at the
will never on tell her I'm let through
for this many yards yeah that many yards
right but they'd done Hanning and LeSean
McCoy you know I ran into him on
offseason down in Miami we would go grab
something to eat together over at all at
prime 112 and where he was talking and
he was talking about the kind of season
he was ready to have man you know he's
such a little competitor and and he was
having that season so I like what I see
in Buffalo in New York the Jets
I mean did Jess just run in New York
right now and this was this was supposed
to be a tanking season this football
thing yeah it is the most unpredictable
even though my job is to predict and I
am the best of the business I do it and
when it comes to perpetuating what's
about to happen on a football field but
it's the most unpredictable insane great
thing in the world it's just being great
you know Mike I have a pet peeve when it
comes to analysts when they talk about
Ezekiel Elliott with the Cowboys when he
doesn't play well somehow the off the
field issues are bothering him but when
he plays well apparently the off the
field issues aren't bothering him so the
last two weeks not bothering him but
then prior to that
they were bothering him can we stop with
that because this is a guy who today may
be suspended for six games and he had an
unbelievable game against Washington but
they're bothering him their display to
think they're affecting the situation
now after certain place what becomes
difficult is it's for the Cowboys hey
you know there's your backs against the
wall every game now has to be a playoff
game that was a playoff game yesterday
yeah so so sore later it's just like I
tell people arm you know where I was
when I was when I'm playing it's a man
you're furious shut up I'm not a
psychopath I'm scared to a coach doesn't
say that I had no fear courage says I
had an ability to overcome fear okay now
you're going to issues and he's going
through issues and it's bothering him
it's bothering everybody on that
football team but at some point the
issue that are having in front of them
they have another issue within that
issue yeah this is a huge situation with
a dick you Elliott but if you don't win
this game your season is basically over
anyway so here comes another huge
situation so now your knees must-win
situations so you put down the one issue
the face of the other but the other
issue and right now they're bats are
gives the wall basically the rest of
this season because of the start that
they've had and the start that
Philadelphia has got now you bought into
the Eagles oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yes
yes now now without Peters that's a
that's a big mess right there I saw
yesterday
they beat the 49ers without him and I
want to say that because I bring my
experience into my job and I think about
when we lost Eric Williams that's why we
ended up losing a 94 championship game
because that one player can be that
import to the football team when I
wanted to get my line ready I didn't go
up and down the whole line I would think
Eric were you picked up but ready and he
got them ready now is our if that is
Peters that guy I didn't see yesterday
but you may hit a show up against better
things if years that God because without
Eric
additional just some teams but it showed
up and then 94 severance again it's
Michael Irvin the playmaker joining us
Thursday Night Football the bills and
the Jets did the Texans overreact to Bob
McNair's comments I don't think so
I mean when it came down and came down
and it sounded and that's all you heard
was like it was from your honor towards
the players but did he miss speak could
can you give him any leeway even if he
said it's the expression is the inmates
running the asylum and he said the
inmates running the prison is there any
leeway and even if he says the inmates
are running the asylum is it still that
offensive that you're going to take a
knee and who knows how this you know
that whatever the fallout is with the
Texans this is what we like doing we
like to be able to determine how
offensive things should be to other
people mm-hmm
which i think is impossible for us to do
true this all of that plays off each
person individual experience through
life so like I shouldn't be that
offensive to you there should be that
offensive to you do that you can't you
know Mike would it be offensive to you
if somebody said the inmates are running
the asylum yes objective would be
offensive initiative been offensive to
them now no donors come back it up now
there and let's put context to this yeah
because he's backing up now saying that
you know I was saying that about the
people I know that's wrong that's wrong
yeah you're right but now also they also
also obviously there's been other issues
from what I gather with with with that
with Bob with farming there are dressed
as things that people have thought and
he's and he said so now that I have
total understanding of it all but I
understood they had a guess of one
Slayer old and now because of which I
thought was crazy what he called his
political views their honors political
news
which blows my mind and that's a little
bit too crazy but but yes that would
have that would have offended me coming
from my owner did you see this story
with Zack Miller they're trying to save
his leg after breaking it yesterday in
New Orleans oh my god that was that was
I felt so bad for him it is it's amazing
that we've seen you know amazing in a
sad way that we've seen this two times
in such a short time because we watch we
watch a word go through it with the
Celtics and then turn right around and
see that again yesterday it was just it
was very sad just start praying for for
the person in the family and all that
they'll experience any other teams we
should keep it on you give me one that
we should keep an eye on here for good
or bad that you being the great
prognosticator that in let's say a month
from now I'm gonna go yeah Michael Irvin
was right a great fear that's what they
call this okay great see great fear
instead old spiritual term and I played
Frankenstein yesterday and had to come
up with the team that could rise from
the dead even though I knew there was
some fans still on the coffin yesterday
because that King was playing the New
England Patriots but man why do San
Diego does st. agur does is every year
started out slowing and they'll just
start rising up you so wow I don't know
if you want to play that teeth san
Diego's looking like that team right now
I don't know if you want to play that
team now it'll be hard for them to
continue crawl back in this thing you
know cuz you got to come through the AFC
which I think it's much more difficult
than coming through here NFC they do
stupid things home right in the Chargers
beat themselves all the time it's
supposed to be an easy game but it's
never an easy game especially once they
get going I'm telling you man watch
those shots man especially with them
boys up front coming bolster and I know
boards where he runs that past most a
bad boy oh that's a good pass rush
uh-oh Miami Hurricanes at Virginia Tech
then Notre Dame how did you do against
Notre Dame please I did it'd be great
news everybody
well that's not true money that's not
true then good Mike no today I'd be
alright I've never lost a game to Notre
Dame the floor states the floors all
those guys I beat them all the time okay
I apologize that's all I just ask the
questions Mike I just I didn't know T is
there just the truth the gospel did miss
all of us bill Mike it's always great to
talk to you the great seer Michael Irvin
the great fear I like that's Michael
Irvin Hall of Famer NFL Network analyst
he won three Super Bowls and you did for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]